all of famer warren moon how are you
Warren I'm doing great rich how you
doing this morning I'm doing fine this
punt this punt return that nobody really
saw coming and then when it was
happening people didn't see it coming
what was your perspective on it well I
think our special teams and as a whole
really let us down yesterday but yeah
that was a huge play as well cuz it
turned into a touchdown but it looked to
me that the Rams did a nice job of
decoying their of their returner which
which was on one side of the field and
then the ball was kicked to the other
side of the field the thing that I don't
understand is from our special teams
standpoint do we not know which
direction our punter is planning the
football I guess good right in the
huddle I'm putting the ball left and
everybody should know that that's where
they're going to go boo goddess of where
their part returner was but it was a
great play by the Rams it was something
I'm sure they saw in film study that
maybe our our Gunners just take off to
wherever the returner is no matter what
they don't really look up for the
football and they got us on that one and
that was a fake punt reception which you
rarely see and then the actual
conventional fake punt took place with
mere minutes to go just when you thought
that Johnny hekker would be punting the
ball back with less than three minutes
down to the Seahawks would get the ball
back that fake punt they hit him with
that that was that was one of the
gutsiest calls i can remember what about
you Warren yeah it definitely was a
gutsy call but it's also a team that's
one in four at that time and and just
struggling it to try and find something
that to get a win if that if that
somehow isn't isn't communicate if that
somehow isn't executed all of a sudden
now Jeff Fischer is going to be
second-guessed you know right out of
town probably if they don't execute that
play properly anything could have
happened the receiver could have dropped
the football or or the punter could have
threw a bad pass but they executed it
properly and they made the play that
they needed to make the Seahawks had a
return on that play that they had a
right return figure than they were going
to get at least a chance to return the
football because their punter is such a
good punter that they probably wouldn't
have to fair catch it but they probably
would have had a punch say phone right
there they would have been able to to
to cover that play but they didn't so
the Rams guessed right in all those
different situations and they ended up
winning the football game because of it
what is the mood of the team you flew
back with the team what was it like you
know that team is pretty even-keeled win
or lose she's really hard to get a feel
for them and I talked to Russell Wilson
for a while on the plane and and we went
over you know some things that he did
good and some things that he thought he
could do better and and he felt like the
team is going in the right direction
with the with the percy harvin move
being made now and he's always
optimistic so it's really hard to get a
judge of what it was from him there's no
question this team is disappointed they
don't feel like they're playing as well
as they need to be playing they have a
lot of injuries on both sides of the
football they're trying to cover up
right now and and you look at every game
that they've lost this year they've had
a chance to either win it or tie it on
the last drive so they're in every
football game they're just not doing
what it takes to win them so what do you
make of the Harvin trade everybody's
saying essentially that Darrell Bevell
couldn't figure out a way to get him the
ball and that was rubbing him the wrong
way and he became a locker room issue
certainly with the quarterback would you
agree with that assessment it was a lot
of that you know Richie knew what now
Percy Harvin came in here he had some
some personal problems and some
personality problems he had had those
same problems in Minnesota but they felt
like with the locker room that they had
built here in the environment that they
built here that he'd be able to come in
here and they could welcome him and make
him feel a lot more comfortable and at
ease than what he was in Minnesota but
it just didn't seem to play out that way
over the course of this last year and a
half and there was a lot of personality
conflicts in the locker room because one
thing Pete likes on this team he likes
guys to play with an edge he likes guys
that that have a chip on their shoulder
guys like Richard Sherman guys like kam
kam chancellor guys who were low round
draft picks to felt like you know they
were overlooked and they have something
to prove a Doug Baldwin who was
undrafted free agent will you bring a
percy harvin in the end of that type of
environment he's a very competitive guy
as well and he's a very sensitive guy
and and it just didn't always seem to
flow very well as far as the chemistry
in that locker room and I think
us one thing that Pete always prides
himself on is he can get guys to play
together and that's a very very close
football team so when he saw that
started to break down that's when they
felt like maybe it was time to move him
on because he didn't want to destroy the
great chemistry that's been built around
here over the last four years I got 90
seconds left with you I want to try and
hit two questions with your first one
are you concerned about the Seahawks
thank you sir I'm really not i just
ladies need to get healthy bodies back
on the field and they will it's just
like the 49ers they've got a bunch of
guys are missing on defense I think when
those guys get back in the next couple
of weeks you'll see a much more improved
team I think you'll see the same thing
with the Seahawks once they get their
healthy bodies back and lastly the
number 5 10 that peyton has now hit in
terms of career touchdowns he's going to
be in the bust gallery with you one day
what do you think about when you hear
that number 5 10 he's one of the the
quarterbacks that I would continually
pay to watch play because the way he
plays the game and and he's probably
going to throw another who knows 80 or
90 touchdown passes before he's done the
way he's playing right now and it's
talent that he has around him you know
just a great competitor a great prepare
a great worker a great historian of the
game and he deserves everything that
he's getting right now because he's
earned it you think he's going to get
600 if he plays two more years you'll
get 600 all right Thank You Warren Moon
I appreciate that thanks for calling in
I appreciate all right thanks a lot
richer I look forward to the next time
that's Warren Moon here on the rich
eisen show the rich eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience